-Welcome to the show.
-Thank you.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
-It is nice to see you.
I'm a big fan of yours.
-I'm a big fan.
-Wow. I love this.
But how long are you
in New York for?
-I'm only here until tonight.
I leave right after tonight.
-Okay.
-Right after this.
-Have you had fun?
-Say hi to my Philly people,
the Roots. Hey y'all.
-Yep, yep.
-I've had a good time.
I had to come do
a Disney event yesterday.
-Yeah.
-Or Monday.
I had to do a Disney event
where you go, like, tell people
what your show's about
and they give you money.
Um, yeah.
-Yeah.
And that was fine?
It all went well?
-Except for I ran
into the ever-elusive,
ever-terrifying David Blaine.
I almost said David Spade
because I just saw him,
but he's wonderful.
No. David Blaine
did magic to me.
He did magic to me, y'all!
-Wait. What do you mean?
What do you mean
he did magic to you?
-To me.
-No, no. What do you mean?
-I mean, he walked up
to a group of people.
David Blaine has an exciting
new show coming out,
so free promo for him, but...
He was testing the magic out,
and he came up to me
and I was talking
to a man from ESPN.
And he asked, "You guys
want to see a magic trick?"
My Christian Black self
said, "No."
Very quickly.
But the man I was with said,
"Yes," and he heard that "yes."
That man had a big, deep voice.
He went, "Yes."
So it was like --
That's what he heard.
-Yeah.
-So he takes out the card.
He has me put my hand in a fist.
I'm scared of him.
I just want y'all to know.
That's why I didn't do anything.
-He's been on the show.
Yeah, he's --
-He's scary. I heard he
coughed up frogs or something?
-He threw up a frog, yeah,
on our show, yeah.
-That's scary. It's funny and --
But it's scary, so...
-Yeah, Questlove
passed out, yeah.
-Did he?
-Yeah, he passed out.
Wait. So he --
-Okay, so he tells me
to put my hand in a fist.
-Uh-huh.
-So I put my hand in a fist.
But the other hand --
He says, "Here, pick a card."
I pick a card. He said pick --
You know, whatever.
"What's the card?"
I say, "8 of diamonds."
And he said, "Oh, okay.
Well, then pick
either 8 or diamonds."
And so I picked an 8,
and he was like,
"Open your other hand."
There was an "8"
written on my hand.
-No, he's amazing. So that's it.
That's when you leave, right?
-I almost closed
the fist back up
and punched him in the face!
-You go, "I'm getting out."
-That's when you think
it's over.
I said, "Okay, thank you, David.
Thank you."
And I was secretly like...
So, then I tweeted about it,
because I wanted people
to pray for me after that.
So I tweeted -- I did.
I don't mess with magic, y'all.
I wasn't allowed to watch
"Harry Potter."
I don't even watch the team
the Magic play.
I don't --
-You did tweet it.
-[ Laughter ]
-I don't!
I'm not watching it.
-Orlando Magic, no.
You go, "David Blaine
just did magic to me.
This is not a joke.
Please pray for me for real.
Just rolled up on me and
magic'ed all over the place."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-I wanted prayer and protection.
-Yes.
-I wanted -- So, I tweet that.
I think everything's fine.
-Yeah.
-I have wine.
I have a good time.
-Sure.
-Later on in the night, David
Blaine does his presentation,
because he has his new show
on Nat Geo.
And at the end of it, he's like,
"And my next guest actually
tweeted about me tonight."
And I was like, "No!"
-"We're done! We're done, man!
We're good!"
-And I was like,
"I'm not getting up."
And he's like, "That's okay.
I'll come over to you."
That's not his voice.
I'm making him way more --
I don't know
what he sounds like.
-Yeah, he doesn't talk
like that at all.
-He doesn't talk like that
at all.
-"I'm coming over to you!"
That's not David Blaine.
He's very like --
-Yeah, he's actually...
-"I'll come over to you."
-Yeah, that is what he's like.
That's really good.
-Yeah, thank you.
-So he goes,
"I'll come over to you!"
And then...
-David Blaine.
-Comes over,
and he sits next to me,
and then he says,
"Is this your wine?
Can I have a sip?"
In my head,
I'm saying, "No. COVID."
But then I couldn't say anything
because I was so scared.
And I said, "Please don't
make me disappear."
And he said,
"I just want to know
if I can have
a sip of your wine."
And I didn't say anything,
and he bit my wine glass
and chewed it and ate it.
[ Audience groans ]
-He ate the glass?
-He ate the glass.
-He ate the glass and ate it.
The guy is unbelievable.
-You see this?
That's not even the worst part.
-Yes, it is.
-No, it's not.
So then I'm sitting there
minding my business.
This is happening to me.
And then he says, "Pick a card."
I said, "I did that once,
and look where we are."
So I had to do it,
and then I picked a card.
And then it was 8
of something else.
I think 8 of clubs.
And he said,
"Here, put it in my wallet."
I said, "Okay.
Please get away from me."
And then he did a move
and he was like,
"I'm going make it change
into the 8 of hearts."
I was like, "Whatever."
So I just opened the wallet.
It's not there.
I said, "The card's not there.
You suck. No."
But then --
-It's unbelievable, this story.
-Isn't it ridic--
I promise it's ending soon.
-No, I love it.
-Oh, before that, he took
a picture of the card
in my phone, you guys.
My phone,
Quinta Brunson's phone.
Took a picture,
and it was the 8 of clubs,
and he put my phone down.
Opens his wallet.
The card's not there.
He says --
I said, "Oh, you messed up."
He said, "No, I didn't.
Look at your phone."
[ Laughter ]
-Again, if you close your eyes,
it's like David Blaine
is right here.
"Look at your phone!"
-I look at the picture
in my phone.
It had changed
to the 8 of hearts.
And that's when I was like,
you know what?
No -- I don't mess with him.
So, David, if you're watching
this, don't play with me.
Don't -- Don't --
I'm not playing with you
because --
-Alright. We get it.
David, we love you.
Quinta, I want to talk
about "Abbott Elementary."
-Yes, yes.
-Congrats on the show.
-Thank you.
-I heard about it.
Everyone loves it. I go --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you, guys.
-Do you know, the show's
audience has quadrupled
since the pilot first aired.
Quadrupled.
-Quadrupled.
-Yeah, that is --
It's a massive hit.
And I heard about this,
and someone's like,
"Trust me.
You got to watch this."
And I go, "I'll check it out."
It is so funny.
It's just -- I haven't seen
a really kind of funny
new sitcom in years.
-Thank you!
-And it's kind of
like mockumentary style
set in an elementary school.
And it's funny. And I mean --
How do you set it up for people
if you haven't seen it?
It's for the family, by the way.
Everyone.
-Yes.
To set it up, it is a show
about a group of schoolteachers
in Philadelphia.
It was inspired by my mom,
who was a kindergarten teacher
in Philadelphia.
She was my kindergarten teacher.
And then I went to the school
where she taught
for the next five years,
and so I just got to see
a lot of behind the scenes,
which kind of inspired
the mockumentary style,
just being behind the scenes.
And it's about teachers
who do their very best
in a Philadelphia public school,
which is very funny, and...
-That's right.
--...inspiring and interesting
and makes you think a little bit
about the state
of public schools in America.
-That's right. I love it.
It's a great show.
You do a great job.
-You're so funny.
The writers. Great job.
-They're so great.
-Everybody. Actors.
Everyone's good.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Quinta Brunson
in "Abbott Elementary."
Take a look.
-So this Zach,
he lives with you?
-Yeah, he just moved in
last month.
-And that's going well?
-Yep, he's so great.
-So, he knew you
and was like, "More!"
-Well, I think he sounds like
a really neat guy, right?
-Oh, sure. Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Hey, there's my guy.
-Black?
-It's actually pronounced Zach.
You must be Ava.
-You were all thinking it.
I see you.
Don't look at me like that.
-We always look at you
like this.
-It's very nice
to meet you, Zach.
-Well, if it isn't
my pizza-crust queen.
-We went out to eat last week,
and I ate all his pizza crust.
I don't like to waste food.
-It's fast. It's funny.
Quinta Brunson.
Check out the first season
of "Abbott Elementary"
streaming now on Hulu.
Come back whenever you want.
Thank you so much.
-I will. I will.